c'est dans l'espace détente de la gare
de saint pierre des corps qui est
installée la boîte à b d une jolie boîte
attrayant tout choisir lire une
trentaine de bandes dessinées avant de
les reposer ou de les emporter en voyage
entre deux trains les voyageurs sont
séduits moi par exemple j'ai souvent une
heure d'attenté entre mes trains ont pu
être sur mon téléphone chauffe que c'est
ça change c'est c'est ludique et puis ça
nous permet de cultiver un peu
chaud
conteuse
en voilà un qui dit chochottes
c'est super sympa et
ça fait passer le temps ça évite
d'attendre qu'un tel et des attentes
manga cette boîte à bédée le fruit d'une
collaboration entre gares et connexions
sncf qui cherche à promouvoir la culture
dans ces lieux de passage que sont les
gares et l'association à tour de bulles
qui défend avec son festival du même nom
l'accès à la bd pour tous on est
convaincu que c'est un outil de
littérature un outil artistique est
absolument formidable donc une boîte à
bd ou du coup l'accès est complètement
gratuit où on est dans le partage à
défendre complètement les valeurs que
nous on a pour le festival à tour de
bulle à apporter les premières bandes
dessinées aux voyageurs devenir aussi en
déposer échanger partager c'est le
principe de la boîte habiter c'est le
cros et comme toute boîte à livres c'est
nous on a les montrent nos collègues
l'alimentent le public aussi a les
clients bien sûr en prenant je suis sûr
qu'ils vont amener d'autres hein ça
c'est quelque chose s'est vantée dans
les esprits du public maintenant dans
les gares de la région centre val de
loire il existe déjà une boîte à livres
à vendôme vignes et bientôt à orléans
et si vous avez oublié votre bd pour le
trajet les distributeurs à histoires
courtes vous attendent encore sur le
quai